hey I'm Ryan and I'm Andy and we're here
a movie clips with our Golden Globes
wrap up Andy let's talk about some
highlights okay number one Tina Fey and
Amy Poehler they should host everything
ever if they could host my birthday
party I'd want them absolutely um
they're hilarious
there are referent they're really
charming every time they're onstage it
really lightens the mood the second
thing that I thought was great was the
Woody Allen tribute now Woody Allen
famously appears at zero award show see
what's the Oscars once and it wasn't
even when he was nominated so we knew he
wouldn't show up but Diane Keaton was
really charming the compilation that
they did of movies that he's done it was
also incredible to watch that number of
famous movies and just in a row I
thought that Alfonso Cuaron for gravity
was really really funny and really
charming um he's a great director and to
see him up there very deservedly winning
I definitely enjoyed Matthew
McConaughey's acceptance speech and I
just really loved Jared Leto as an actor
so I was really excited to see him in
his acceptance speech so a few surprises
from the night Brooklyn nine-nine
winning Best Comedy no one really saw
that coming same with Andy Samberg
winning Alex Ebert winning for all his
lost were John Williams and Hans Zimmer
yeah kind of like seasoned vets he was a
young guy he had long hair that he
pinned up and he did this weird kind of
cool acceptance speech lose the warmest
color didn't win Best Foreign Language
Film which everybody
I assumed it was a shoe I hadn't seen it
but the trailer looked amazing yeah yeah
and it's been getting all these
accolades and attention there's been
some negative attention in terms of how
the stars interacted with the director
apparently the director was a real
tyrant it's a great beauty one which I
also hear is amazing so that is I think
but it was it was still a little bit of
an upset all right so the Golden Globes
are kind of leading up to the Oscars
they're kind of like a little cousin of
the Oscars so let's talk about what last
night meant for those what I took away
from it Cate Blanchet is the person to
beat in terms of like for Best Actress
it seems like she's unanimously going to
win in terms of Best Picture nomination
it's yesterday was really spread out her
won some awards 12 years of slave
American hustle 12 you slave 1 best
drama in American hustle comedy so we'll
see how that kind of plays out when
there's not categories that way American
hustle which I thought was kind of
losing momentum ended up gaining a lot
more last night by winning major major
awards yeah probably held the momentum a
lot especially as it's kind of like
seeing its run in the box office at this
absolutely it's doing really well you
have Amy Adams - Jennifer Lawrence both
winning Nebraska they think that Bruce
turned even though he didn't win last
night he still may have a good shot at
winning an Oscar for Nebraska leading
into the Oscars I it still it really was
spread out there's no sure wins except
Kate Blanchet so that was our Golden
Gloves recap yeah comment below and let
us know what you thought about the show
who won and what it means for the Oscars
coming up until then I'm Ryan and I'm
Andy thank you for watching